you
you
good morning Millennials Wow genuine
good morning millennial I'm really just
like running on fumes here because I've
now left the house on a school night two
nights in a row in full glam and this is
the first time you and I have done the
show or really me have done the show
five days in a row how are you feeling
I'm so tired
did my user who nights out really make
things difficult in heels in heels like
I just keep waking up the next day just
so exhausted I'm so happy it's Friday
night I know all of you are even happier
I love the weekend know I love good
weekend I see tomorrow I'm gonna sleep
until four o'clock p.m. I wasn't asleep
till a reasonable hour and spend some
real quality time with my son because
that's what's important to me sleeping
with him no resting there's a difference
you're gonna take him for walks in the
park no resting there's a difference
between sleeping and resting and I think
it's important that we discuss the
differences one is like I get to enjoy I
don't get to enjoy sleep because I don't
know I'm sleeping but I'm like looking
around I'm like I got nowhere to be
nobody to talk to
got my television my husband my son this
is life how is he oh he's precious I
mean literally I like there was a time
where like I was really gone for like
two months straight and I would come
home and he'd like didn't know who I was
or he was mad at me like I couldn't tell
and I was like really paranoid that he
was like starting to forget that I was
his mom I think he really started to
think that his home was Ben's parents
house because he was spending so much
time there like that made me really sad
so now we're like back and we're
spending so much time together that he
started to sleep in my legs now not in
Ben's where it's like he wouldn't even
talk to me and like two weeks ago just
go straight to Ben's crotch he's so cute
I was actually hoping he was gonna be
here today I was supposed to bring him
but the time what the dog-walker didn't
work out yeah I know damn well I'll see
him later yeah you know enjoy in the
fruits of his cuteness announcement I am
coming to Detroit Michigan and by the
way did I show you this have to show you
the like maybe like on all the things
that have happened to me this might make
me feel the coolest cooler than a
billboard
no but just still cool
so I'm gonna be in Detroit Michigan
January 12 I think tickets go live at
noon today
sale is already started and those
[ __ ] found the link and posted it in
the Detroit toasters and they almost
sold out to be happy being great so like
you better get your tickets and on the
website this is what the website looks
like wow it's like the schedule of
events at the Royal Oak Music Theatre
January 10th AEG presents oh what a
world tour with Kacey Musgraves January
12th AG presents an evening with girl
with no job like that's [ __ ] cool and
a great transition at or what I'm
assuming is our first story um sort of
okay well maybe not oh what is the
Grammys no that wasn't our super yet I
have a lot of oh yet either and they do
want to talk about to me because um
yesterday Mason Ramsey posted a giveaway
for his blog and I saw you searching it
out toasters tagged me I must have
gotten over 2,000 tags no luck there's
33 thousand comments when I checked last
night for sure but who could have gotten
more than 2,000 tags no but are they
counting who got the most tags yes each
egg is a boat I don't know but it's rigs
because I haven't won anything yet
people how long are they keeping it
going for 24 hours I spoke about all the
Instagram yeah like not only the money
he puts it on but unseals in sir not
only do I need to win premature Mason
then he recognizes but he need to
recognize me and I'm his number one fan
I agree and so whoever is doing the vote
counting it is rigged
did you and I don't think Mason even
knows that he has corrupt people working
for him but like Lee's the votes no
nobody won yet how was it every Howard
announce winners oh I'm sorry I thought
that was just one winner
how many people have what [ __ ] you're
like oh you don't even know the fact no
my job because I didn't [ __ ] watch
Mason Ren's Instagram all night like you
did a parent well I just haven't won
anything and like over 30 people have
one step no one has more tags than me no
one so have corruption over at little
Hank Williams
have you watched white Christmas music
but no why I don't know like I've heard
the songs actually so you mean it I just
some Christmas songs like are done and
that's actually funny because I saw one
of our stories today also in like the
era of people not
like there's there are a few Christmas
songs that no matter who thinks them or
how they're just not good yeah and like
there are also some songs that no matter
who sings them no matter how bad they
sing it like they're always a Bop and
that's a true testament to ashley
tisdale last Christmas yes last
Christmas all I want for Christmas Bob
season like but I wrapped it up and sent
for the Christmas song like what's up
chestnuts roasting no honestly like I
like my loins start to turn when I hear
Christmas music like I love it oh I love
it
you know actually know what [ __ ]
stupid-ass song I can live without
jingle bells
oh but have you heard Rascal Flatts
version it might turn you maybe I like
Candy Cane Lane bye see ya I love Candy
Cane Lane rice yeah
do you know this I use it in hallmark
movies it's in a commercial by the way
so like doesn't I you I had heard it
before hallmark doesn't use real music
except for Candy Cane Lane but so that's
how good it is yeah well what did you do
I have a Spotify playlist called Jackie
hohoho and it's actually the best
Christmas playlist of all time feel free
to take a gander what did i do last
night I was at Barney's at the page six
dialog oh yeah we had like a long
metaphor not it started so early sorry
it's so early and it was so cold but we
looked so cute Jack and I went to launch
of page six tile at Barney's and they
actually gave out gift cards and it was
like a Russian roulette thing so it was
like all the gift cards are at least
$100 but some of them can go up to $500
so I need to go and see what mine is
seeing but they also could have just
said that for them everyone's is a
hundred and they just think that they
didn't win yeah and then we thought like
Barney's was more generous than they
were totally but it was fun we ran into
the housewives in New Year's a melissa
gorga
Marge and the new one and I Jackie I
kept calling her Jennifer there is a new
ones and now is Jack she's stunning like
in person Chanel earrings she no bingo
Chanel charm bracelet Chanel dress
Chanel shoes Chanel bag everything
Chanel her face was so gorgeous she said
we're just and she was so little like
she wasn't much taller than us and on
the show she comes off as a tall girl
like guys not but she's so small and
frail and that's just really crazy how
you can think someone's tall on TV I
hope people think we're tall yeah no I
think they know that we're not TPG is
any
reference to our size and you really
made like put it into perspective how
sure we were know where Kristin was
filming behind the scenes stuff and
sending it to us and like we literally
look so short we were also Jackie and I
did an interview on page six video
something I don't even know what it was
and honestly like it might be our
greatest interview ever we were being so
funny and like we were like just talking
to each other
honestly it was in that moment that I
really realized like you and I live on
our own planet cuz we really making
jokes like I didn't even finish the joke
and like you knew what it was ya know we
were being out of control in the woman
behind the camera was laughing but I
don't know if it was because she like
felt she was laughing and then she was
like to the guy delete all the footage
it was so funny they were like what is
on your holiday wish list and Jackie
World Peace and I was like I didn't
remember the exact line from convention
what is it from Miss Congeniality but I
was like and I want harsher punishment
for good whatever oh my god we were
being so fun and then we made like a
LuAnn reference they were like what is
something you recently splurged on and I
was like I bought a Louis Vuitton okay
like you walked in you came to
understand your Herman Munster shoes
like nobody knew what we were talking
about but you're being so funny and
honestly we just need to get that video
for real they don't need to post it
where no like I think we answered
straight for at least one or two
questions so just use that a celebrity
crush seperti chase Momoa oh that's a
good one I said I had two John Eyre and
Kate Upton who do you want to kiss under
the mistletoe was the question it was
yeah oh you know I'm even listen when
people talk no but like the gist is
celebrity crush no I'm pretty sure she
said the word celebrity crush no but it
was holiday themed so his kiss under the
mistletoe and one of the men she said
who's your celebrity crush then you
would want to kiss under the mistletoe
oh for sure like she that's the word
celeb right now it's like if you're just
who we do want to kiss under the
mistletoe like that would be weird if
you don't say your own oh and Kristen's
watching on YouTube Kristen is our Betsy
who works at page six nice and please
get us the footage and weirdos that
we're taking about unless we look cute I
just like I saw I thought it was feeling
my look to Ed T then I saw a [ __ ]
picture my gut and I was like gut City
my gut my gut was telling me it wasn't
good
exactly no I like I felt good I had a
gut feeling but I just
there were so many like orifices that
could have been hanging out ya know and
I just couldn't keep track of all of
them who else soon we see dr. oz was
there he's just like literally an angel
and him and Ben are best friends and
every time I see dr. oz mitem Ben's wife
and it's like now I know how Ben feels
you know and Jordan sparks is there and
I just have to say she doesn't get
enough credit for being the hard-working
thirst monster that she is because I
only run into her at like thirsty events
and she is like the thirstiest one yeah
look in the brightness color jacket with
the camera crew following her but she's
like the biggest like biggest fit like
she goes to small pounds where she can
be a big brother that's a reason she's
not going to the Grammys it's a tactile
like strategic move to be a big fish in
a small pond yeah as a thirst monster
myself I see the angle and I appreciate
it right but then it's like you could be
the big fish in a small pond if you went
to other extremely extremely thirsty
dehydrated ribbons but you don't do that
so you could be the Jordin Sparks of
let's say oh yeah bustle style right
would you rather be like the coolest
person at bustled style launch or be
like and absolutely nobody at like a
page tic saying where the let's say
there were so many famous people there I
think this the latter the one that we
but the latter yeah I don't want to be
more opportunities for growth for sure
no but would you rather be the coolest
person at page 60 launch Jordin Sparks
or the lousiest person at the Grammys
Jordin Sparks
no the losers pursuit the Grammys I
could see it like 15 throw oh that's
good yeah I would take it okay also I
went to dinner with my friend on last
night and she's getting married she
wouldn't like everyone around me is
getting married and it's starting to
annoy me
do you want to get married no it's like
I had to deal where you renew your vows
I had to deal with the treachery and I
have to go through it again with you and
Olivia and Anna
no one is bringing like bothering you
with anybody it's not too bothersome
it's just like the feeling do you don't
even like the dress but like I remember
your wedding like you didn't bother us
I wasn't like no and I know that no
one's bothering you no no it's not the
bothering thing it's just like that type
of energy I don't want to be wrong but
no one's putting you around it
oh no it's just like I'm not here for it
I'm making you come for it and also Anna
was like to me last night she was like
by the way where's Olivia registered
like so we can get a gift and I was like
where is Olivia registered that's why I
have midnight I literally wore a middle
the night Michael vo where are you
registered I couldn't remember where is
she registered I don't know I think
she's I just went to play she really
doesn't bother us with her Bridal stuff
because I didn't even know where she was
registered it's great where are you
really certain I'm registered at
Bloomingdale's did you ever make your
wedding website was olla of course I did
yes my wedding experience um my
experience was so positive and they made
it so easy for me too what I was really
worried about is like I didn't want it
to be zillow.com
such Zachary - Jackie - one two three
right dog Suzy really made it really
easy for me to just get sake Oh calm oh
so they get they helped you get the
domain yes oh that's that was my
favorite part and then the rest is like
makes it for the the format's are so
easy photos here about us here registry
here wedding information here cute it
was it's really great I highly
recommended that was like one part of
the wedding planning process that was
like daunting for me was like a wedding
website yeah it very technologically
advanced using Zola I get a grandma who
doesn't know how to use microwaves right
using so like it in an hour and I'm so
glad that they reach out to us because I
probably still wouldn't have one
otherwise well you can join 500 other
couples who have used Sola to five
hundred thousand oh my god that five
I'm so sorry let's start that again join
five hundred thousand couples who've
used Zola to start your free wedding
website or registry on Zilla go to Zola
comm slash toast
vol a.com slash toast
they make spread they make registering
for newlywed life so easy and I just
have to say there are very few things
about newlywed life that is easy so if
you can take one thing off your list do
it also the thing about registering a
lot of people register at different
places and then it's like you need a hub
for all three or however many I not
having a issue like go to Bloomingdale's
or stay home or write a check so
actually when Olivia's gonna be one of
those people cuz said she needs like
she's a chef so she needs to go to chefs
Plus like chefs plus yeah
chef's chef chef calm williams-sonoma
well so actually when I did my registry
first I read to start up Bed Bath &
Beyond Bloomingdale's in William Sonoma
I was like I want all three price points
because I don't want it to be like a
thing for anyone
Bloomingdale's and then will in Sonoma
and when I actually went to
Bloomingdale's to physically like do the
gun they had [ __ ] everything a $2.00
knives and $2,000 knives so I cancelled
all my other registries and someone
actually ended up sending me something
from my bed Bethenny on registry I don't
know how she found it literally the
second before I deleted it and I like
was so disorganized like I ended up
going to Bloomingdale's with like the
cups from Bethenny on to return and they
took that oh my god
that's so funny she was like giving me a
hard time she's like we haven't sold
these here in a while I'm like well some
about them I used to ride the stirrup at
Bethany on no matter how many people
suggest it because I just feel like
anything that you're buying me from Bed
Bath me I'm like isn't a gift it's a
chore you know what if you're buying a
vacuum you're giving me a job to clean
I'll buy a vacuum cleaner when I need it
that's not a gift to me buy me some
porcelain you know no barn so buy me
some designer handbags like anything
that's like gonna be used for me to
clean the house like that's not a gift
give me some baccara totally and then
like if I'm ever in a pinch I'll sell it
yeah you'll give me a job get me the
Karl Lagerfeld buy Christoffel egg of
silver right no get me Hermes China
Versace for me but I guess you're more
of an Hermes go so it is our esteemed
pleasure without further ado to jump
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast now even
though we've teased two out of the five
stories today I'm going to start with
the story that we haven't east yet
because it's really sweeping the nation
Kevin Hart rejects academies demand to
apologize for past homophobic tweets so
last night Kevin Hart posted quote I
just got a call from the Academy and
that call basically said Kevin apologize
for your tweets of old or we're going to
have to move on and find another host
Hart said an Instagram video posted last
Thursday night quote I chose to pass on
the apology the reason why I passed is
because I've addressed this several
times that this is not the first time
this has come up I've addressed it I've
spoken on it I've said where the rights
and wrongs were the Motion Picture
Academy did not immediately have a
comment on whether they had demanded
Hart apologize and if they plan to dump
him for his part Hart said in a video
quote regardless Academy I'm thankful
and appreciative of the opportunity if
it goes away no harm no foul then later
salep said cuz I just went into all the
steps of the story Kevin Hart has
stepped down I
the Oscars host Kevin Hart said Thursday
night he's stepping down from 2019
Oscar's just 2 days after getting the
gig in the wake of criticism over a
series of homophobic tweets he posted
years ago ago quote I have made the
choice to step down from hosting this
year's Oscars this is because I do not
want to be a distraction on a night that
should be celebrated by so many amazing
talented artists he wrote in a statement
on Twitter the announcement he would be
quitting the show came just minutes
after he posted the message on Instagram
saying and the Motion Picture Academy
officials had asked him to apologize or
they would find another host and he
refused to apologize
despite that statement Hart did offer an
apology in his later resignation tweet
saying I sincerely apologize to the
LGBTQ community for my insensitive words
from my past so I am having such a hard
time formulating thoughts for so many
obvious reasons and I in no way want to
be hypocritical and I really don't know
how I feel about this because I don't
know like a part of me is like dude just
like you're about to get the honor of a
lifetime they're giving you the
opportunity like we got cancelled and
nobody [ __ ] called us like they're
giving you the opportunity to make it
right like run with that it's like you
can make history like they're always
getting the Oscars it's like never
inclusive it's like you are an
african-american comic and you are
hosting like just do it like make
history and they're giving you the
chance like do you know what I would
have done for the choice to just explain
so I'm like a little annoyed I'm just
like [ __ ] by the way like I always
try and think of it like okay let's say
it wasn't homophobic tweet so it seems
anti-semitic tweets I always try and put
that mindset cuz that's what I think
would resonate most with me and I'm not
gonna lie if it's an oh if my son grows
up and bury a Jewish girl I'm gonna beat
him I'm like this [ __ ] game
so it's like you know what I'm not
doubting anyone's live want any
neccessity for an apology like it was
hurtful and [ __ ] own it own at least
I own it but at the same time I didn't I
didn't know about this at all but
apparently it's come up many a time he's
issued many an apology and really like
has explained so it's like how many
times is this gonna come up right like
either is he cancelled or not it can't
keep coming up right and he's apologized
for it so I think for him it's like if
he apologizes again then that doesn't
put it to bed then the next big
opportunity that
can be taken away from him comes up and
this comes up again he apologizes again
I think he just wanted to put his foot
down and I don't think he's thirsty
enough for this Oscars role right well
that's what's so crazy like imagine they
didn't they didn't take it away from him
cuz they gave him an opportunity which
is so crazy
because imagine he stepped down like
that is just so wild imagine being so
rich and famous that you didn't need to
host Oscars like separately right well I
mean honestly he's so for like I was
surprised that he was even doing it in
the first place because it's become such
like a loser II event and he was just
gonna make it like really funny but I
guess not
but here's the thing so you've we've
went through this we apologize
you move on with your life like you're
doing new things and really making a
positive impact and I think Kevin Hart
overwhelmingly has a positive impact on
people like I think he has a positive
attitude and just really wants to bring
like light and humor yeah every
situation so say something next comes up
and then you like everything's brought
up again right would you apologize again
well so I don't I mean I'm a people
pleaser and like I'm not at the point
where I'm rich and famous enough where I
can afford to do that but at the same
time it's like I I don't know I mean I
feel like I might be unique in my own
opinions like usually I think I'm right
about everything
but it actually thinks like my own
personal experience and the personal
experience of other like someone who's
gay or in the LGBTQ community like we're
all gonna have different opinions here
because they all have different life
experiences and given the the scenario
that happened with us it's like I have a
I just think like what I would have done
like I feel like he was given an
opportunity to make it right like which
nobody gets like they cancel you and
you're done
like he that's such a rare opportunity
and I kind of wish he had just acted
upon it and been respectful and
apologized to the people like cuz I
think I'm like okay let's see he
apologized many times would he be saying
[ __ ] about Jewish people my one-on-one
if you're gonna be on my TV I want
another one like and I'm a title to that
because you and the LGBTQ community
titles that so many actors in Hollywood
are a part of the LGBT community so make
movies in that are not going to be
nominated
I have LGBTQ themes like I'm sorry I
think he could have just done it I don't
know but also I'm not into like apology
cancel culture to I don't know see I'm
all over the place I don't have a
definitive opinion and I'm not gonna
certainly follow my sorting and trouble
for saying something about Kevin Hart
right it's there's months a lot of sides
everyone's entitled to their opinion I
agree with you that he could have just
squashed it
I respect him for not just do it like
doing what everyone told him to do you
know for standing up like he did
apologize how many times is he gonna
have to apologize and when are we gonna
move on also the cancel apology culture
and this need that people have when
someone gets a major opportunity to just
ruin it like he's been up here for years
I'm he's worried he's worked so hard
come here for him then and he gets an
opportunity and like instead of being
happy for him just how can we ruin and
this just makes me like sad for our
futures like cuz I didn't feel like I
really thought that I mean I didn't know
that it had already happened and been
explained and he had issued the formal
apology so like the fact that it's now
coming up for like he said this is like
the third or fourth time like great for
us no well honestly but I think when
people think of us I think that they
think of they associate that with us
yeah of course right but for Kevin Hart
I'm the biggest Kevin Hart fan I had no
clue about this so I think it's more so
like people on Twitter have brought it
up he's apologized like but it's never
been like a national news story right
and I do believe that this will be the
last time for him well he also like has
had many a national news story including
this whereas like we were some nobodies
and we got national news for absolute
like it didn't fit the like I said we
were nobodies people everyone was
treating me like who is this girl no and
it's like all these publications are
writing us up but we have never been
with ever absolutes like who are these
people and so people who have never
heard of us which is the majority of
people now only know this about us great
no but and then it's like we never know
one doesn't know one doesn't not know
bro oh that's true you know right
could've Jake how did you hide in our
pen I didn't know no so it wasn't that
prevalent oh maybe it is maybe he did
the like if you're a big Kevin Hart fan
and you don't even know maybe he did
need to apologize yeah well I mean he
eventually did apologize I appreciate
him apologizing to the LGBTQ community
yeah it's like I can't I can't demand an
apology and I can't really form an
opinion on this because it doesn't
affect me like I am NOT someone who
could be hurt by this but I mean
obviously I think it's bad but I'm not
right here I'm not directly affected
you're not in any position to say
whether or not these tweets are fences I
can't make that
ship and knock dictatorship decree
decree but I was reading some really
insightful comments on the in the
morning show search page by both
straight and gay people and I just
thought it was interesting and it was
just a mixed bag like this is the thing
there's with a situation like this
there's no like he's wrong he should
apologize he's right he shouldn't like
there's no nothing
I um I'm right in the middle and I don't
know to say especially given what
happened cuz like you see the tweets and
you're like oh that's bad but it'd be so
much you'd be like oh that's bad too and
they were bad you know and you apologize
right and I'm I think that it's really
important in the words of Teddy
Mellencamp to be accountable but at the
same time we have to really as a culture
understand like I was watching Friday
Night Lights and Matt Saracen literally
in a couple episodes says the R word
[ __ ] like hundred times and like and
sometimes when I watch friends the
things that they say I'm like huh like I
would die like if that happened today
and it's a really proof that like we
live in a totally different world and
there needs to be alright and so rules
of of 2018 shouldn't apply to words of
2008 because who would have known like
at the time those weren't offensive
things to say right necessarily depends
on what it is but like there were some
words that that now have more offense
behind them of theirs that meant
something honestly very different ten
years ago a a hundred percent agree and
literally friends is the testament to
that like the way they talk about
Monica's weight or Chandler's daddy's
transgender it's like what like they
it's they use [ __ ] like it's just we
live in a totally different world and we
need there needs to be some sort of
learning curve and this whole cancel
culture I'm not into if you want to stop
supporting someone great but here being
like let's cancel like I [ __ ] hate it
which are parts quarks yeah no it's
crazy
it's terrible so and having been at the
brunt of it it's so like not that I'm
trying to make myself the victim like
it's so hurtful in like literally it's
the scariest thing like like form your
own opinions of people based on your own
experiences and just do that no but it's
also so interesting like in situations
like this the people who are coming with
the pitchforks we're never Kevin Hart
fans to begin with so it's like it
doesn't necessarily change his
Larrin II put Chucky now most important
but just the people who like who are the
loudest of course just get their voice
but most importantly there is a spot
opened up now for hosting writers aside
from us and I don't think given what
happened tests were the best choice here
and I don't why I keep saying what
happened to us like what happened who
who should it be okay maybe a woman I
really do think that they won't be able
to top Kevin Hart and I think it's gonna
go back to like Andy Samberg level of
disappointment you know yeah safe right
and so I had to take back the words that
I said the other day which or that I'm
no longer excited to watch the Oscars
well actually yes coming we don't know
who's coming I'm sure it'll be a very
safe do you think they're gonna joke
about this probably probably I mean I
don't I don't know because it's so
interest it's like usually this stuff is
so like the person who who's in the
wrong is walking on eggshells will just
say don't the thing that will make it
right you know and he's just being so
defiant and like in the fact that he's
already apologized so right it's like
even if someone were to make a joke
about this like he would joke right back
like you're not crawling into a hole
that's the other whole element it's like
we also need to look at this through the
lens of like he's a comedian and where
where you draw the line for comedians
I'm like who are we to as a society like
dictate what a comedian can and can't
joke about do you know any mean right
even though like I don't really think
it's a joke saying you're gonna be your
son if he's gay because that sounds like
a real thought but whatever but a great
like comedy is if you guys want to ever
laugh again like there has to be some
things that that people can say that are
that are gonna scare the others well
here's the thing now now that I'm like
actually like I I don't think I'm a joke
of a comedian anymore like I think I'm a
comedian you are and I check to do I'm
like can I make a joke about the fire
uh-huh and you said no mm-hmm and you
were right but like you Teeter on like
my whole shtick is I talk about what's
going on in the world and what's going
on a pop culture Miley Cyrus losing her
house like so where do you draw the line
and like I don't think even if I had
said it would it have been like a big
deal but it's like I just didn't wanna
be insensitive and II didn't wanna hurt
people's feelings but like when you're
on as big of a platform like Kevin Hart
is the biggest
in the world and probably in the history
of comics like just in terms of numbers
like like everything you say has to be
looked at through that lens of like well
this is a joke and a 20-18 can't do that
no they can't so I guess we just will we
won't laugh you guys I'm honestly like I
had a pin about talking about it and I
was gonna say coming not do it as a
story even though would be like so
obvious but it's just like I feel like
my opinion like our opinion of it is I
don't know are we are we off like I
don't I mean I don't know I don't know
what my opinion is right it was just
afraid to like step and [ __ ] me like
well you get it and how many [ __ ]
tweets of people talking about Kevin
Hart do they tag me in with cardia to
this like a hundred threads of people
who think their intellects lets a guy
get off Twitter man
I favor liberating oh I know it took
every now and then someone like thinks
that you're like like a scholar and goes
on a rant about like 2018 and I was like
tagging me like making no I I understood
not talking about it like not wanting to
talk about it because we definitely have
a unique experience right but I think
that's also why we should talk about it
and we're looking at it from every lens
I still don't know like like I were gave
me reasonable what I would have done
what should be done
what's but well if it was me I just
don't I think like and I was in I was
him like I was a man I would not want to
pass up the opportunities like to make
history and like I don't think he
understands how big of an opportunity it
is for them to have given him a chance
like usually when this thing happens
that people are quote-unquote outraged
like it's done peace peace right he's
alright you're done go home like you
don't even get to breathe before you
find out that you've been cancelled so
to have been given that opportunity
which never happens to anyone I'm almost
like pissed at him for letting that go
and that's all I'll say understand
before my tits pop out understood well
speaking of 2018
sorry that we're about to talk about the
daughter of man who wrote baby it's cold
outside blames Bill Cosby for ruining
the song because the quote say what's in
this drink reminds listeners in the me
to era of his conviction for drugging
drugging and sexually assaulting a woman
so before we go into this can you please
look up the lyrics for me yeah as I've
heard this controversy a lot they say it
on Glee and I'm not
I know what the what the thoughts are
but I've never actually read the lyrics
oh I'll read the lyrics too but I'm just
gonna read a little bit more of the
story the daughter of the composer
behind baby it's cold outside has blamed
the recent controversy surrounding the
Christmas classics predatory lyrics on
actor Bill Cosby
so some radio stations aren't playing
this song this song is like on the verge
of cancellation yes and it has been for
years but um I guess now it's really
coming to the surface Susan Loesser
daughter of the late composer Frank
Loesser said Thursday on NBC news that
Cosby who was convicted in April of
drugging and sexually assaulting a woman
is quote ruining for it for everybody
the famous song written in 1944 takes
the form of a duet with a man trying to
convince a protesting woman to stay over
because quote it's cold and outside okay
I'm gonna pull up the lyrics that's not
the the what's in this drink isn't the
only lyric that people have it's
alarming isn't it alarming who'd of ever
go to pool baby it's cold outside and it
says baby it's cold outside ban okay
good
I'll keep going okay
too much Splenda Oh means it's only half
a covenant he's our whole spunda
I really can't stay baby it's cold
outside I gotta go away baby it's cold
outside this evening has been so very
nice so very nice I'll hold your hands
wait why don't we just do at it okay
curtsy this one okay do you want to be
the predator the credit II I'll be the
predator just cuz I have a lower voice
like a man okay let me say that's true
so you sing what's in parentheses oh oh
great I get shafted - the bad lines the
same three words no you're fine I really
can't stay it's cold outside I gotta go
away it's cold outside this evening has
been so very nice I'll hold your hands
they're just like my mother will start
to worry what my father will be pacing
the listen to the fireplace so really
I'd better skirmish it over to be just a
half a drink cold outside she's trying
to leave and he won't let her the
neighbors might think say what's in this
string I wish I knew how to break this
spell take your hands and hold oh I
ought to say no no no mind and then you
Predators say mind if I move in closer
why ask permission I'm gonna say that I
tried what's the sense in hurt and my
pride I really can't stay hey baby
okay there's more okay whatever
in my soul at the end of the day after
all for protesting he convinces her to
stay and that's a little no-no in my
soul do I think that the man who wrote
the song was writing it like I'm gonna
get this girl lock her up in my house in
Chains no is the song a little odd 100%
are there [ __ ] terrible songs that
say terrible things about women that get
played on the radio yeah so why doth
protest this one particular song I agree
look I protest truffle butter okay no I
mean yes if you look at it through the
lens of the predatorial nature of men
these days it's predatorial well I just
look at it through some cutie she's
playing hard to get trying to leave but
you can't even believe him it's like say
that phrase and more playing hard to get
because it's like if she's saying no
you're played again right but okay let's
pretend she's playing hard to get but
we've all been there I don't know did I
believe he's asking her to say okay I
don't know it could be either and it's
like I just think like if we're gonna
get offended by a song I could give you
so many more like that should be more of
a priority for us yeah
like it's weird a hundred percent I
don't think the intent is when it was
written to be like predatory because I
don't know it was just a different time
but like uh if we're all if now we're
looking at lyrics in an analytical and
critical way and we want to start
demanding respect in songs I think we
could start somewhere a little bit more
important I agree also I don't know if I
agree with the daughter that it's Bill
Cosby's fault she's crazy this has been
like a topic of conversation every
holidays a word association when you
hear roofie what do you think one two
three hey party okay the movie
ruphylin okay I think like frat party
like dudes trying to [ __ ] girls like
putting rubies in their drinks when
they're like 18 year old douche Lord
it's like that's what I think I don't
know so seating I don't associate
roofing with Bill Cosby so the homegirls
wrong okay the daughter but also it's
not just that one line that's
controversial it's the whole message is
she's trying to lead and he won't let
her and she's saying no and he's
interpreting it as
and you know yes means yes is a very
serious movement and what's she being
coy or what did she want to leave we
just need to talk to the girl that's all
man wrote it courses through his Latin
so it's the male gaze it's through the
man oh my god that's literally the male
gaze like I never understand what the
male gaze was in college and they're
always talking about gays no I know it
there's something else I want to talk
about this song please that really
bothers me about it that it sucks oh
yeah that's why that's a so [ __ ]
singing over each other's alone oh it's
such an annoying song regardless of the
lyrics like I really don't like anyone's
version of it so for that reason I
wouldn't play it on the radio I like one
version of it and I'm hoping that the
song doesn't get cancelled by a like
society because then they won't be able
to play elf the movie when so we just
shower and he's like baby it's cold
outside
okay ready for the next story
sure Grammy Awards nominations 2019 the
complete list Wow okay I was so excited
this morning when I woke up until I
wasn't record of the year I like it
cardi B bad bunny J Balvin the joke
Brandi Carlile considering I've never
heard that song I don't know what your
girl Brenda Carlyle was nominated for a
million things and I literally have no
idea she is and I want to say she's
country just shame she's this is America
childish gambino God's plan Drake
shallow Lady Gaga Bradley Cooper all the
stars Kendrick Lamar and says a rock
star post Malone featuring 21 savage the
middle said Marineris gray prediction
the middle cuz it really was the record
of the year the second thing I wanted to
tell you we just hold our tonight it's
important actually I like it we turn
around I had something I wanted to say
but I don't the Grammy nominations um oh
I was reading Rolling Stone this morning
about the biggest snubs and they said
most obviously is that shallow was
nominated in this category but the
greatest showmen was in but greatest
showmen was no no wasn't we're thinking
oscars as the time is different and
Rolling Stone said that and greatest
showmen is nominated in a bunch of
random categories visual whatever so it
is eligible for this year's nominations
and this is me or the greatest show not
being put in this category but shallow
is like really odd just because in terms
of the numbers and Grammys in the words
of Kanye West they sell you they say
you gotta sell it to smash the grab me
you really a lot of the what goes into
the nominations is record sales and so
the greatest showmen not being a part of
it is very odd I'm pissed yeah oh my god
I didn't realize that now I have to look
through everything through the lens of
greatest showman now obviously album of
the Year nominees album of the Year
nominees okay so invasion of privacy
cardd by the way I forgive you Brandi
Carlile scorpion Drake H er by H ER beer
bongs and Bentley's post Malone dirty
computer gentleman a golden hour Kacey
Musgraves Black Panther the album music
from and inspired by various artists
okay so black panther can be nominated
for album of the year rose oh [ __ ] is
great showmen or even star is born yeah
so when I read this my first like I
oughta bleed gas because I can't believe
that reputation wasn't nominated and I'm
gonna say something controversial and
you might be shocked by it but in terms
of the numbers like okay so an
interesting statistic is that all these
albums combined didn't sell as many
records as Taylor stuffs at reputation
she sold over a million and them
combined didn't even sell a million so
like just four numbers alone she deserve
to be nominated but I don't think she
deserved to be to win because as I think
in order to be a real stand of someone
it that means being honest and as much
as I'd struggled with this concept
I don't think reputation is her best
work and I don't think it's indicative
of her true talent I think the songs are
good I think the way they were produced
is really - she got too techie and she
got too obsessed with like the theme of
the snake and the reputation I mean she
doesn't really want to just get back at
Kanye and Kim so as a fan I'm like sad
that she wasn't nominated she deserved
to be nominated just for the sheer fact
of she's selling out a million albums
which nobody has done in the past ten
years I read a statistic six albums have
sold over a million copies in their
first week and Taylor strip was four of
them she deserves to be nominated and
recognized just for that number but I
don't think it was the album of the year
song wise I really have a feeling that
Kacey Musgraves is gonna win and I think
like she deserves to win I don't know
all these albums so I I can't say um but
she's the only album I've listened to
backwards and forwards and it's
incredible work of art it's an
incredible work of art grant the Grammys
respects Kacey Musgraves like she won
Grammy awesome
me amazed even yes and I think it's
actually it's so hard to weight off your
first album she won country album of the
year for seem trailer different Park and
she won new artist of the year like they
respect her and this new this album is
so beautiful like I think she's gonna
win and it's even less country than the
other like it's less of a cell for the
indeed like Grammys are almost like in
the same category as like when Beck won
like do you mean like just alternative
like unclear what does that mean Kanye
is gonna come through well I don't think
he's gonna go by the way do you think
Taylor is gonna go well she is she
nominated for any hop vocal she's in the
same category as sweetener and Camila
Quebec but it's not gonna be announced
on TV Pop Vocal album yeah it seems kind
of specific no but it's Shawn Mendes
Ariana Grande can I look about Taylor
Swift like that's not pop album it is it
is okay wait let's continue
song of the year wait sorry I want what
I wanted to go back to the totient thing
is so not only did they snuff her there
but not any of her songs were nominated
like as anything well okay what song off
her whole album would you say is like
with the one that you would put in for a
nomination delicate really yeah it like
broke all the the numbers like it was
number one on pop radio for so long and
they everyone said it was bad and then
it literally became number one like in
the world that's so interesting like cuz
I don't even agree that I got a single
it's not she never really said us a
single I would never know I think she
did no she didn't oh yeah I think she
knows video yeah um I wouldn't even put
that one forward so it's like if we
can't even agree on what the best song
is and how or any of them nobody's snubs
are just like it's so pertinent it's
like if they don't wanna give her album
that you're she didn't give her anything
else yeah like her being in the same
categories are none grande I'm sorry
like sweetener it's is so not good I
agree with that but Ariana Grande is if
it's Taylor Swift wants to swim in the
pop pool she's going up against Ariana
wow that is so true that's the level
that you I I know this is mean but like
I hope she's better this is the only
thing Taylor Swift cares about like she
cares about the Grammys she said in her
1989 World Tour like all of 1989 was
inspired by random-access memory it's
like her not winning album the year for
red all she [ __ ] cares about his
album of the year all she cares about as
the Grammys she's devastated I know
nothing affects her this is affecting
her that's and I hope I hope that this
just like leans her back into her pop
country 47 I hope she needs hang out
with Casey mask
who wrote the most inspirational caption
when she won the CMA Awards which is
that she really doesn't do this for the
awards like or that she's so happy to be
able to make be making music and making
rubbin 11 Mukesh show Network show
Network show Network show Network show
that the pictures from last night are
relatively cute
um she's so happy to be able to do to
like be doing the thing that she loves
in like living off of it that that's
enough for her but winning getting the
sort of um what's the word recognition
recognition really is so nice and Taylor
stuff needs have that approach to like
it shouldn't be all recognition know
this is what he doing I by the way um I
don't actually know that that is a true
statistic but like it's definitely the
vibe that I get like she cares about the
Grammys you saw she sent all the Grammy
like voters VIP like things yeah oh my
god that's so sad I know song of the
year and this is different than record
of the year because I feel like we we
should all be able to agree on what the
song of the year is and now we're gonna
we've spoken about this before I'm let's
make our decision all the stars
Kendrick Duckworth Oh Kendrick Lamar and
scissor boot-up LMA God's plan Drake in
my blood Shawn Mendes the joke Brandi
Carlile I gotta listen to this song the
middle Zen Mary Morrison gray shallow
Lady Gaga and Bradley Cooper this is
America childish gambino so funny song
of the year cello has been out for a
month the year really song of the year
is the middle um
record of the year gambling I like it
isn't nominated for song of the year
cuz I would have said I liked it cardi B
is boudic yellow last year yeah but I
think I like it is really the song of
the year because I think it has got it
equal to more play as the middle but it
also is like it's bilingual and it
really is like an anthem and the middle
is a and it has a lot of musical
elements to it whereas the middle is
just like straight up pants yeah no but
song of the year was the middle like it
played on every radio every restaurant
I've ever been into like well
considering I think actually God's plan
might win it's the most streamed song it
was an event of the year yeah and the
video was so great yeah
good nominations Best New Artist Chloe
exhale e leu combs Greta Van Fleet heard
do a lip I'm Margo price bebe Rexha
gorgeous Smith have you
of Chloe exhale II know okay so they're
that I think they're sisters are so
gorgeous and they opened up for Beyonce
okay I feel like I'm speaking actually
like I don't know what anything about
them but there's blogs about them about
Beyonce I need to read them oh cool yeah
um obviously lucam says my vote bebe
Rexha I love and do it but I love I
actually feel like they cancel each
other out though in this category cuz
how can one win over the other they're
both super talented and had great years
and great songs do I think if it was
between the two of them do ellipta takes
the the cake even though meant to be was
like the song of the year like one two
three pick up the phone you know he was
only calling cuz he's drunken alone she
really she had a great year this was a
great year for dual epi' but I really
like they love Davis the Grammys
respects country and treats it as equals
like crispy Appleton one new artists in
the year what is it two years ago I
think Luke Combs has a real chance
especially oh my god those spotify
statistics that have been coming out I
found wildly interesting cuz Marin Mars
had six hundred and fifty million which
is so crazy because the middle was the
song of the year Luke Combs who didn't
have like one song that went crack chily
he did when it rains Poor's 500 mil
crazy crazy but also Marin didn't have
an album this year so Oh 650 is really
all the middle that's crazy yeah and
people like us who can't stop listening
to her first album yeah best solo pop
performance colors Beck he's a pop
artist now Havana
Camilla Kibeho God is a woman Ariana
Grande Joanne where do you think you're
going Lady gaga better now post Malone
you know what I personally win this she
must have done a live rendition that oh
yeah I think she did that's up for pop
performance because a lot like Havana's
live yeah if I were the Grammy voter I
would give it to Lady Gaga but I do
think that post Malone is gonna get it
and and I would be happy with that
choice because you know I'm a big post
II fan now for what reason I played him
Adam oh no that was crazy but when we
watched the the last award show the AMAs
oh yeah I'm pressed by him they all fit
you know I like them his performance him
and everybody likes him yep and everyone
respects him Best Pop Vocal album
Camilla by Camilla Kibeho
meaning of life Kelly Clarkson sweetener
ariana grande Shawn Mendes by Shawn
Mendes beautiful trauma
pink reputation Taylor Swift who would
you give it to repetition honestly I
would give it to beautiful trauma
hey I know I know but it's not going to
her no but a
and Kelly Clarkson's here and Ariana's
here and Taylor's here and my perfect
rock bottom beautiful drama my love my
love oh oh sorry sorry okay actually
know what those are the most interesting
test let's actually go best country
album unapologetically Kelsea Ballerini
port st. Joe Brothers Osbourne girl
going nowhere Ashley McBride Golden Hour
Kacey Musgraves from a room volume 2
Chris Stapleton golden hour or Chris
Stapleton but considering KC's the only
one nominated for best album doesn't
that automatically mean that she's the
best country album but let that would
have to make as if Chris Stapleton was a
better country album he would be nominee
for Best Rue makes you think ok next
story following two stories our bachelor
related stories so everyone can sort of
turn their brains off except for this
first one that's our nation's Peter
Krause and Bibiana are casually dating I
went to to expand beyond this morning
then I realize they don't have her phone
number I wanted to get the scoop I'm
working on it but she's listening now so
B I mean it was offended this story
broken the toasters and somebody so much
news has been breaking the toasters and
like no one's giving the group credit
it's so annoying
well this is actually so funny how it
got broken because bleacher report
posted a random video from a sports game
Whiteside got benched for the entire
fourth quarter so we decided to leave
early just like another tweet a day in
life of bleacher report the Nana video
is Viviana and Peter sitting together at
a sporting event um honestly I don't
know I mean we'll have to talk to maybe
on and get the full scoop but I truly do
you need to go like right now yeah okay
so hasn't happened to me in a long time
but like I'm literally about to put my
pants maybe I'll read the rest of the
Grammy nominations while you're gone are
you going to come back okay
finally we're alone now I can talk about
Claudia
just kidding she's a wonderful co-host
sister friend and mother to the ohm not
as good of a nun sweet just as I am but
how can you how can you be Wow a
one-woman show pressures on
anyways I'll continue reading the album
the Grammy nominations because I think
you guys care about some of these
categories that we don't care about and
we're nothing if not caring so Best
Dance Recording Northern Soul by above
and beyond
ultimatum disclosure losing it Fisher
electricity Silk City and dua lipeh
ghost voices virtual self considering
I've only ever heard of one of these
songs and it's [ __ ] incredible the
Grammy goes to electricity Silk City and
do a lip oh wow it's nice not having it
any dissenting opinions best rock song
black smoke rising Jacob Thomas Kiska
Greta Van Fleet jumpsuit twenty one
pilots mantra Bring Me The Horizon mass
deduction st. Vincent rats ghosts never
heard of any of these so the best rap
song for me is gonna go to panic at the
disco whatever their latest song was
best urban contemporary album everything
is love the Carters The Kids Are Alright
Chloe and Halle Chris Dave and the drum
heads Chris Dave and the drum heads
Warren leisure Miguel ventriloquist
the shell name I can't pronounce um I'm
gonna go with the Carters everything is
love because they're the only artists
I've heard of here oh no I know Miguel
but I don't know his album best rap
album invasion of privacy cardi B
swimming Mac Miller recipes victory lap
Nipsey Hussle Daytona Pusha T Astroworld
Travis Scott the Grammy goes to ash your
world so that Kylie will arrive at the
Grammys hopefully with stormy in tow or
cardi B of course so we get a fire
acceptance speech but I'd rather see Ty
Lee there cardi will win for something
else probably I like it
best jazz vocal album my mood is you
Freddie Cole the questions curtailing
the subject tonight is love Kate McGarry
if you really want rom it in the window
settlement oh wow
best gospel album Oh Tori Kelly's
nominated for Best gospel album but you
didn't know that gospel oh I am I have
one for you that was really quick I know
I was just like I was so bawling at it
yes I'm good you guys I'm crying I'm
good best comedy album I why your comics
okay and by Jim Gaffigan posted the
funnies in serum annihilation Patton
Oswalt equanimity and the bird
revelation Dave Chappelle these sound
like bestsellers on the New York Times
books
noble ape Jim Gaffigan stand up for
drummers fred armisen tambourine Chris
Rock so Jim Gaffigan posted like he's
like really it's actually an honor to be
nominated Congrats to Fred Armisen and
Patton Oswalt and congratulations to the
inevitable winners Dave Chappelle or
Chris Rock I don't know I haven't seen
any of these I kind of hoped Jim
Gaffigan wins because he's like the
hardest working man in comedy and like
doesn't get half the like a recognized
Asian it's funny because recognization I
needed that word before I move it's me
why I got your hard work no but it's
like it's not recognize a ssin it's
recognition yeah yeah I just want to
find the nominations for Best soundtrack
or whatever movie related ooh Best
contemporary Christian music performance
song I'm actually really interested
about of silesia nominee this she's not
nominated for jack-shit but you say by
Loren Dale is nominated and it's the
most beautiful song the only Jewish
person I know who like actively like
watches the Christian charts um and then
you know what Jews like you've got to
get on it honestly the songs are so
beautiful I can take the same Bible and
like the same dog it's technically
Jewish every once in a while they drop
it in Jesus and you know it's okay it's
fine he was a Jew um every once in a
while it's like a little murky but for
the most part it's just so enjoyable
where is best soundtrack its if it's not
greatest showmen it was nominated for
visual live Sun [ __ ] like nothing I've
ever heard of best score for visual
media No
okay whatever visual we can move on back
visual media Best compilation soundtrack
for visual media I guess that's what
they call that soundtrack call me by
your name various artists Deadpool to
various artists greatest showmen various
artists Lady Bird and stranger things
okay you guys if it's not greatest
showmen there's not even competition
here because I'm stars born isn't even
nominated right actually I think the
reason why only shallow is nominated
it's that the movies not nominee because
it was it was released and they probably
released it first so that it could be
nominated for a Grammy next year they
won't have to compete against creator
shown and they can have all of my full
support
yeah unless something else that comes
out
the thing why you can watch as our
darlin I'll never meet the grass
[Laughter]
the deeper watch as I'm diving how never
do I know sweetie all my breath I was
doing no I know but it was really good
um oh by the way happy birthday to og
toaster a lot of Paris happy birthday
so greatest showmen which was also so
crazy Spotify wrapped came out and every
single one of my top 5 songs is from
greatest showmen yet my album that I
listened to most is gold and our eyes I
realize haven't listened to that much
music because like Margo is like 40
million minutes whatever I had like six
I had 19,000 alright sixteen thousand
actually not bad when I used to work a
desk job I listen to millions of people
cuz commutes like yeah when I used to
sit in library music music music but now
my life is just so pop in and I have an
Alexa and they use Amazon music when
they just randomly play on like play
gold an hour
I asked Alexa this morning to play
dancing through life from wicked and she
played dancing through life by the
sheriff's Enquirer and was in French
like any sense
oh my god dance or two though it's hard
to find music that you want to listen to
early in the morning um so halfway
through my makeup I decided on the
wizard and I this morning I listen to my
Spotify playlist the fact did they put
together all of your favorite songs of
all time
ever oh what's about what if I needs to
do and this was about I hadn't another
show but I couldn't remember it and then
I lost it Spotify needs to partner up
with time hop and let you know every day
on like last year on this day this is
the song you listen to most I'm sorry it
was built in caller ID I was like I have
just dropped the comment so I was
reading everyone's like thoughts say
well most I burn things is an amazing
episode Spotify that meets the partner
up with time hop and tell you every year
on this day the song that you listen to
most that it would be interesting
information wait like I thought if I
hear new ideas I associate it with or
they don't have to part of the time out
they can do it themselves and just let
me know the song I listened to a year
ago today two years ago today that'll
let me know like what I was up to what
was my mood like I can see pictures but
what was I really feeling but also we
can announce by the way oh okay yeah
this show this is just weird jump in but
Wow honestly like I haven't had a
moonstruck moment like that in so long I
feel like that used to happen to me a
lot when I was like really fast I was
like eating
portly and you want to know what it is
this morning before you got here I had
three of Entenmann's cookies like you
can't do that and God punished me and
gave me a big old Duty no God beauty
isn't a punishment dude he's a beautiful
thing
totally and milk thistle has changed my
life I went to dinner with my friends
last night and they hadn't heard a
missile and when my friends was like I
haven't pooped all week and I'm like you
have got to take notice where did you go
to dinner last night Bond Street
anywhere you would recommend it was so
good I only wouldn't recommend it
because for a while Bond Street was the
hottest restaurant in New York
you went packed City you had a
reservation you were reading it out
really just like a sushi joint it's not
swanky but you didn't care because it
was the coolest place in like you were
at the place it's a lot less cooling out
it's a lot less busy and they still have
look we had a reservation at 9:00 and it
didn't get seeded till 9:30 on a
weeknight and it wasn't that busy like
that pissed me off I'm sorry but you had
a good meal so it was really no mom I
had a like a fantastic meal I'm so happy
for you
thank you let's go back to our
announcement wait Ariana baby Jana baby
on M Peter okay so you can live like so
here phille I'm unbelievably here for it
like when I think of my favorite
bachelor people I think of Viviana who
would I set her up with there's no one
worthy when I think of Peter who would I
set him up with there's no one worthy
the two of them already not said this I
think we I think because here we asked
her and she said they're friends so this
is my only trepidation is I don't want
to get my hopes up that they're dating
when like maybe this was a first date or
even just a hang to test the waters
maybe this was our first time meeting in
person then all the press like Peters
him
right or it didn't even go well or it's
nothing yet and you just can't count
your chickens before they hatch so bibs
Peter if you're watching I'm so here for
this you have her you have our blessing
a thousand or whatever you need from us
and we're gonna make it work whether
it's tickets to this show or you know us
to not talk about it in order to give
you guys a real chance whatever it is
we're here for you yeah no seriously
like make babies they're both so
beautiful and they're both so normal
like they're not fazed by the show and
they were like fan favorites and they
have this whole new life but they're
really committed to like staying in
their hometown it's like the only thing
I don't think the word worked out it
would work out because Bibiana never
wants to leave Miami and Peter never
wants to leave Wisconsin yeah they'll
have to mean the middle in Oklahoma I
don't know where they then why don't you
just meet me in the
uh-uh okay what was the final story
about The Bachelor Colton's ladies have
been announced did you watch all sets of
Dallas yes okay we'll talk about after
you know thirsty moves to get eyeballs
on this season they posted the group
photo as well as the BIOS for all of the
girls and I'm just gonna run through
their names or know their professions
cuz some are interesting I feel like
they've stopped with the really kooky
professions and now just some
professions that we can make fun of like
how content creators someone was a
social media participant right last year
but it really did turn out he was like
sort of a social media model
Angelique who's a marketing salesperson
taja Juan who is a business development
associate Annie who's a financial
associate from New York City Wow
she sounds like a great guy she's really
pretty front runner front runner how do
we miss her a blue dress but for a
moment these pictures by the way don't
do anyone any papers it's hard to even
I've ever seen Alexis waters this
picture it's my favorite thing and the
only thing better than the picture is
the story behind it and the shoes she
wouldn't see her shoes so she wore my
clothes yeah and Hannah is Miss Alabama
from 2018 oh my god that is so classy
girl Courtney is a caterer
Hannah gee is a content creator from
Birmingham obviously very easy
progression to make fun of however so am
I know by the way I don't take any up or
dress it with this I mean I pay my rent
on time I just bought myself a Louis
Vuitton suitcase like you keep doing new
Hannah J she's also cute as a button but
ton she's cute as a belly button
these are better pictures than the
moment saw yesterday we saw the clothes
yesterday yes they're from far away
Sydney who left her job as an NBA dancer
to compete on The Bachelor cute it
depends what team you on I think if this
was a good move yeah Devon is a
broadcast journalist respect the hustle
Tashia is a phlebotomist Wow what's up
um she's lobotomizing she enjoys the flu
bottom part of the bladder a lobotomy
kasi is a 23-yard speech pathologist
thank you for your work and thank you
for just like having a real job right
and I used to go to speech pathology
class and obviously what did they teach
you Sally sells seashells by the
seashore
dead-ass
to do what Sally yeah but also because
my friend Keith hadn't grown in yet so
of course I'm gonna have a list but I
guess they wanted to just make sure yeah
in the budget that when they came in I
didn't get into the pattern even though
I was very Pro Lisp it's kind of sexy
depending on who you are I totally agree
so like I'm at well I guess if I had a
lisp now I couldn't do this show because
it might annoy too many no but lose all
of our viewers
people are very acute like an aware of
people's voices we know so for the job
that I want and the job that I have I'm
glad I went so thank you Cassie for the
work that you do we have a Sales Account
Manager we have a realtor we have an
interior designer
we have Jane whose real name is Adrienne
and she's a social worker okay my name
is Corrine Jennifer whatever we have
Alex he was a dog rescuer a noble
profession I love her we have an IT risk
consultant ooh gorgeous - from Dallas
here for you we have a recruiter we have
a medical sales rep we have a dental
hygienist I don't know why but like the
dental hygienists on The Bachelor just
never farewell or never find their way
into my heart yeah it's like they've in
conventional men too much in their real
life like education that they're not
gonna risk it all on some show that has
an expiration date
did you see you know there's no longer a
part of the box right okay also by the
way these girls seems like they have
great jobs and these pictures and I'm
seeing now are way better than ones I
saw yesterday so I really hope Colton
did find his woman he is what he'll heal
on Gale who was like famous for being an
actor pretty to be the most famous other
guys there's also just like so funny and
great on Twitter and Instagram is no
longer about your producer he knows a
lot and we've got to talk to him I'm so
shook I never thought I would see that I
never thought that like that would ever
happen I mean maybe he's moving on up
you know maybe he didn't always want to
be a reality TV producer definitely but
this has become like his whole career
and you had so many side gigs like his B
wrote a book and he had like I feel I
feel like that was just his world
yeah well it's so crazy and did you see
that they released a new poster for
Colton and it's 40 mirror image of the
40 old version he's wearing the same
shirt it's the same it's like a mockery
of the fact that he's a virgin and I
just want to say like the season hasn't
even started and there's already to like
digs at
fact that he's a virgin and like I'm
just so not here for it I feel like The
Bachelor is contributing to like the
statistical to disgusting culture that
we live in that like hates virgin it's
like what's wrong with being a virgin
I'm just like I'm angry and I mean like
a little and right at Colton's going
along with it like he posed for that
stupid photo shoot here is the problem
with The Bachelor and then I want to say
something about colt INSERM I mean the
problem with the Bachelor is that on the
one hand they have unrealistic
they set unrealistic expectations about
relationships and sex as it pertains to
relationships and that like sex is like
this taboo thing and unless you make it
to the fantasy suite you shouldn't be
having sex with your boyfriend then on
the other hand someone's a virgin and
they are like made fun of for that so on
the one hand you shouldn't have sex but
you can't be a virgin so you're in that
you could only be like one type of
person who has sex on the eighth day
mm-hmm you know and it's like there's no
room for Humanity right no it's it's so
stupid it's so unrealistic and they're
really just showing like they're
disgusting they know better he should
like have STDs and give it to all the
girls cuz he [ __ ] so many girls like
leave him alone it's so mean and it's
like I'm not I'm not here for it and I
don't support that narrative whatsoever
also controversial statement I love
Colton
michio he lost me a little bit with that
stupid elf dancing video but I'm still
on board until I see the season um I
I've said it once I'll say it again i
slayed you once to make me slay you
again I will not base create opinions
and judge people based on what the
producers have decided to show me and
the narrative in which the producers
have decided to create they wanted us to
hate Jordan Kim believed as a male model
he was mean he was entitled to was it
egotist I met him thought he was lovely
and decided I liked him and now everyone
likes him because Jenna like no and they
oneness like Jenna and she's a con
artist saying they never they never told
us that like you'll have it made right
on that right so it's like I'm done
listening to who Mike Fleiss decides is
likable and who's not I'm gonna pace my
own opinions based off of what I see on
social media if I meet them in person
what I see from the show and try and
look past their [ __ ] narratives and
their crazy
biased edits so I like Colton until I
say otherwise I really liked it too and
if you had told me a year ago when I saw
him on the premiere and I literally like
he was my new celebrity crush like he
was up there with Jason Momoa if you
told me he was gonna be the bachelor I
would have been over the moon and I'm
still
and even I know everyone hates him and
it's annoying right the people that's
just like what people do it's like you
love something so much that you think
that someone was explaining this to me
it's like the nature of troll culture
yeah you get into something you really
like it then you love it you become
obsessed then you love it so much you
become obsessed you think that you own
it then the person does something that
you don't agree with and then all of
that love is reverted into equal hate
when you become a troll where did you
read that um it's like the art of
trolling it's like the six degrees of
totally I think Taylor's record told me
about it that is [ __ ] brilliant and
so true you just start you don't think
we're all normal people you start you
like something your fill of it then
you're obsessed they do send you think
that you own them they do something that
you disagree with and you turn and all
that love that you had equal parts hey I
need to read this article unless I don't
know what yes she just told me about it
and it was just brilliant I thought
brilliant so I love Colton and I know
people didn't like that dancing video of
him I thought it was actually really
cute it seemed like the type of video
that he didn't like staged a photo shoot
to make it if there were Nick vile he
would have been shirtless with a Santa
hat on being like a in a studio on lot C
at Warner Brothers like being a thirst
trap I think and also the song that was
playing was a really good Christmas song
and not your average Christmas song and
I just thought it was really cute he has
such a cute but yeah and I really really
like him and also like he is a former
NFL player like even if you've heard the
bench I don't care he's signed an NFL
contract like you don't have to persuade
mean I twenty five girls are lining up
to date him completely and I said boy
sisters as opposed to some unemployed
Instagram influencer couldn't agree more
and there's no greater testament to
ignoring what the producers want you to
feel then Ari and Lauren so far they
have literally given me absolutely no
reason to dislike them yet everyone
dislikes them and has the most horrible
things to say about them when they
literally couldn't be more in love more
happy to see they announced that Chris
Harrison is gonna officiate their
wedding obviously even though it's not
televised though so they didn't have to
keep but he's going to cute like they're
having a baby they're starting a family
to have a home like [ __ ] off get off
their dick no but everyone's like
thirsty for the people like [ __ ] Nick
vile I'm like I'm coming Jared yeah like
stop I'm really like I'm annoyed
sufficiently and I'm sorry I'm making my
own opinions and I encourage my fellow
toasters
to do the same I'm here for it let's
talk about towels reunion
let's it was a little stupid I'm really
annoyed because I feel like the women
have clearly chosen their sides based on
couches except for Stephanie because
like we've said she is yes like weirdly
jump [ __ ] hurt why I don't know and I'm
upset because I really do like her but
like she is going in on Deandra and like
Deandra can handle LeAnn honestly they
are two like equals strong there's
history they have equal knowledge on
each other and they can go but when
carries chiming in and with then the
Cameron double punch of societies yeah
are in the face she can't take it and I
don't think she deserves all of this
hate
I completely agree and you know what I'm
starting to feel Carey it's like a
sheena all for so long Carey only wanted
to be like a part of Stephanie and
brandy tree over the three of us we love
each other we're naked were jumping and
that's Gina she wanted to be witches if
we go Sheena got the witches we go and
she decided wasn't what she wanted Brit
a Carrie got which is a wee ho [ __ ]
sighs decided it's not what she wanted
and she's turned the [ __ ] up honestly
you're so right I just I really really
like Carrie and I think it's because
when she came on the show you weren't
here that and you never met her she was
just a cool she's a cool woman and she's
gorgeous she's gorgeous she's like
self-aware she's just like she's someone
who's like mom and cause you'd be like
that's not a regular mom that's just
cool mom so I just I still think she's
cool and I still really like her I just
don't agree with the side that she's
taking but it's like with this group
it's like once you choose your side you
have to go hard for it so she could have
chose either side she just happened to
choose the wrong one and now she's going
hard if she chose the right one win hard
I'd like her Camryn is like really
another level like really starting to
piss me off the blind defense of LeAnn
for Knoblauch for no reason they're not
even talking about anything in camera we
like bull against the grade it's like
what is going on no like what does LeAnn
have on her and it really is so
hypocritical how LeAnn can act and say
and do whatever she wants trashy or not
trashy and Cameron doesn't call her out
for it when it's Brandi was grinding on
someone in the tubing the in the bow
down yeah right on the floor huh Cameron
would be so judgmental it's so silly um
Brandi looks so cute like I love her
outfit actually all the women looked
really good Cameron's hair was an
interesting choice but I thought Lee
Anne looked very good
I thought Deandra
I love a pantsuit moment like really
just I was so annoyed when Cameron
called out her nipple
like I'm so [ __ ] rude annoyed and she
could have said it like the way she said
it was like your nipples falling out
where it's like that's like a derogatory
thing to say I thought I would have been
like Deandra I would have done the same
thing so rude I really and especially
because they're already all raggedy
hunter so it's like another thing no in
really for some reason like really
really really I'm with the other maybe -
oh so Brandis wearing the same dress
that Gina is wearing on the OC reunion
and that we talked about mercy - but let
me just say two things about our Dallas
one that whole thing was Stephanie like
really made me cry because when she's
when she was talking about my child and
then she said literally at a time I
would be like in a bad mood my parents
would fly down and sleep on my couch cuz
I scared them so much when I attempted
suicide and like I feel so guilty about
that like I literally could cry like it
made me feel so sad like the guilt that
she has when like she was going through
something and like she scared up here
and so much that they literally flew
down and slept on her how it's like oh
my god - this big secret stupid so
stupid Stu [ __ ] pin that's not that's
not a secret like that's not an action
that's something that someone said it
and it's not even that crazy and also
Carrie getting so mad at Deandra for
believing that that's not the interest
felt her bleeding at its landfill for
saying that was that was crazy and
that's where it's like you see Carrie
just decided and is fighting because if
you if you heard that if I heard Jackie
you told me that Olivia's gonna call me
that what I be mad at you know be mad at
Olivia she's gonna call me fat right
it's so stupid right unless I made it up
right which but I wouldn't make that up
and it's and you're like and okay two
things I want to say one thing about
Stephanie that you were just talking
about not only do I love her even more
for how real she is and like how she is
so I'm like from about the outside
looking in her life is perfect and she's
so honest about that and no buddy's life
is perfect she's so honest and I feel
like the the spaces where it's not so no
one looks at her and it's just like oh
that's perfect I want to be just like
Stephanie because but even though in her
being honest you do think that like oh I
wish I could be as brave as her honest
and and deal with all of her struggles
in the way that she does cuz I think
she's just like so strong also I thought
they really I really appreciated them
dedicating a lot of time to what she was
saying like I don't feel like she was
edited at all like it must have been
maybe like five to ten minutes which is
a lot for me when everyone finalists
stop talking and it was just about 70
right and they could have cut it down
and I thought I really just appreciated
that they included all of it and we were
able to have that moment because that's
what matters in mine I really like love
her so much and I love she's such a good
friend to Brandi and not in the way that
Cameron is Tilly and like you're great
you're right everything you say is good
like she's the first person to tell
Brandi like chill the [ __ ] out you're
wrong go apologize like that's a good
friend what's going on between Cameron
and LeAnn is the weirdest thing ever is
the weirdest thing ever it's a two part
of a three-part it doesn't need to be a
three-part I don't think so either
what I was gonna say about LeAnn oh so
cuz Deandra wouldn't lie about Leon
saying that and Leon has proven herself
that she lies she literally said I lied
about recording the conversation I lied
about saying that I hacked your phone
yeah like she has a trucker has a track
record of lying deandra's never been
proven a liar yet no there's not been
anything that has come out that shows
that the Android lies I wanted to kill
someone when they were saying you lie
you're LuAnn you lie and I'm gonna call
it lie ad I know but then I was thinking
other names are so similar they're both
I am yeah and by the way they wouldn't
they don't know that reference but for
me I was like say it say I add okay once
you're quite oh see really quickly I'm
gonna really try and catch up completely
by the end of the weekend so that I can
fall into the next reunion and be up to
date and I'm very early on him only in
like episode 10 but I have to say I'm
not hating the new Housewives both as
much as I thought I would agree I really
okay so I'm up to the part where it's
like Kelly and Emily made up Kelly went
to Emily's house with the husband after
the party okay but I felt really bad for
Emily at that party like they had pushed
her and talked about her husband don't
get me wrong
her husband's definitely like a dick
he's not a bad guy he has a weird sense
of humor that nobody understands and
he's definitely this there's something
weird about him but he's not abusive
he's got all these things and like she's
defending she came on the show and like
literally became about her husband and
she was being crazy and she was like
I'll kill you but they [ __ ] pushed
her there and I really like felt so bad
for her because I know she was mortified
right but like she was drinking and they
kept saying he's a [ __ ] like I would do
the same thing like I felt really bad
first she like felt protective and I
hate that they pushed her to that point
agreed and also he's yet to do anything
like tit like a lot of these women were
married to some terrible men and it's
like and you don't even get to talk to
all about first husband
so I'm Simon you don't even talk [ __ ]
about them until they're divorced and
it's like not only his Emily's husband
not even done anything so terrible and
when I first heard the story I thought
it was hilarious like yeah did you know
what Sheena was being so annoying on the
ship we did see yeah imagine when it got
late kill the [ __ ] out of my house
Jackie a bed which is like and it's like
Zach did that I would completely
understand plus we have kids plus you're
annoying plus the party is over the
cameras have gone home Vic go home right
so that didn't even like that wasn't
even so strange to me so the fact that
they're riding him and like hard for
something that isn't necessarily that
bad it's like why does he deserve that
like where were you when David beador
Wright was taking the beador stuff right
you know like no one gave David no one
gave Shannon a hard time about David
before she let that I couldn't agree so
this woman comes onto the show
automatically she has to defend her
husband and by the way like but she also
felt in the position where she couldn't
defend him because she would look like
they all made it seem like she was in
this abusive way to clean what he did
was wrong right and you know that she's
a battered woman and that she's only
defending him because he hits me because
he loves me like they created this weird
trap for her right and they cheated me
I'm the option to say by the way what he
did wasn't that bad and I kind of like
might have done the same thing
so she automatically has to denounce
what he's saying but also protect him
and I just felt like these women their
anger was so misplaced Lee excuse me can
someone call up Simon bargain and and
place the anger well so now his shumlin
call up Brooks run place the ingrown so
now they had this conversation which I
have to say in the history of all the
housewife confrontations I thought it
was the most mature conversation between
Kelly and Emily like they just had a
great time at the garden and they were
both mature and I was really surprised
that Kelly took ownership and went to
the house and figured it out and like it
was an awkward thing but like they got
past it and I don't know what happens
after this but for now I'm very happy
like good for Kelly for owning her [ __ ]
which she's not always the first person
to do so she's learning and she's saying
I know I say [ __ ] up [ __ ] I have to
learn how to take ownership of it so I'm
here for a mature ask Ellie I just wish
Shane would have accepted the apology a
little more gracefully and with the
stupid jokes like he's annoying he's
annoying it was very awkward she'd know
Matt like regardless of what like what
Kelly said in her apology like she came
in she apologized it's over at that pool
she's eating [ __ ] like help her right so
the other things going on I mean Steve
Lodge moving back in with his mommy
mommy it was so funny and there is
something weird in Steve Steve I mean
Vicky has terrible taste in men so that
should already be like an indicator like
but my concern is why is Vicky so
obsessed with getting married she's been
married more than once
she wants her love team to be full I
know but it's like she's very very needy
I feel like the only person who will
only the only people I don't I feel like
once you're married once or twice and
you have kids and like your life is full
you but the only people who are fixated
on getting married of people who have
never been married and people who want
kids I agree now see I never like really
thought about it but now thinking about
it I think that she is obsessed with
getting married because right now
technically Steve could leave and and
not come back and she doesn't have and I
think marriage for is a sense of
security that like yes you can leave but
it's gonna be hard as [ __ ] yeah you know
totally you got a fat file the paperwork
and I think like she as much as like the
love team beautiful is like the running
joke like I think she definitely has
this like sense of like needing to feel
like change someone down a little bit
change someone down be in a relationship
and like she's a relationship person and
she also not only does she need the
relationship she needs to know that they
can't really go anywhere without putting
up a fight right she needs the security
of that yes I want to see something
about Gena and Emily and I agree with
you it took me a few episodes at first I
was like why do we even I'm new to bring
back Heather Dubrow okay her whatever
she needs Alexis Bellino even as well
I really am enjoying Gena and Emily and
I thought that the way that Gena handled
the whole thing was shame and never
talking about it and still having
Emily's back you know she was the one
who was wrong huh was so on point I
couldn't agree more and that's when I
started to stop hating her because I
think that it became this huge thing and
Gena never spoke about it like and Gena
would be the person to make it into her
thinking she would have been justified
in doing that but it became this table
conversation with everyone that everyone
was talking about and this is this and
Gena and everyone's brought it up it was
so crazy she really defended Emily the
whole time I think she's a good friend
to Emily and I like them and like a
jeana's annoying in the way she talks
like I want to kill someone but she's
not as bad as I thought but the fact
that they came on together but not as
friends they developed this friendship
through the show I think that they're
real friends you have each other's backs
and I like that and I like that it's not
because of some relationship that we
didn't know about we really see
the day of a new real friendship but I'm
up to the part now where she has decided
to file for divorce like literally the
day before it is so weird so now all the
women being like being concerned like
they're it's fine
Vicki being annoying like Vicki taking
whatever like regrets she has out on
Jeana is annoying me and I get that a
lot of them are like by the way like I
look back and out of my life and I
really wish I tried to make it work like
that is actually insightful helpful
advice but Vicki's saying she has no
moral compass like that's where she
crosses line and I felt really bad for
Jeana even though it does seem like she
woke up one day decided to get a divorce
ya know she she had made her mind up
before she came on the show she
definitely came on the show to get
divorced which I was mad at it at first
I've gotten over it since because she is
adding value to the show I just want to
say something about the women over OC
because when I think about Jeana getting
up from the table at that dinner they
are the worst dress cast yes 100%
they're except I would say Kelly has the
best style me too and she has really
like her style but just as a group no
matter where they go what they're
dressing for they all carry shinobis I
think that it fixes right dressing for a
gala or just going you know on a trip in
Jamaica like just to the beach they find
a way to look not cute you could take
you could really look at all reunion
looks as like a an indicator of the
style and like New York is chic Dallas
is sparkly and loud and very Dallas
Atlanta is dramatic OC is a conference
like it's literally a comp businesswoman
special conference yeah no it's terrible
it's really not good I haven't even seen
the looks from this year even though
Jeana is wearing the same dress that
Brandi wore it does not every Union by
the way jeana's like her body's really
cute really get Q buddy I feel like bad
for her kids are nuts I know and they
keep saying she has her hands full shows
her hands she really does maybe that's
why she didn't divorce Oh half the time
she can get the time off maybe it's a by
the way and I don't know what everyone's
seeing like cancel OC
I'm having a good time so far I'm liking
it Shannon is getting out of control and
I see I see the future for Shannon I
think I love Kelly but I think the
friendship it might be a little toxic
Tamra is such a good friend to count two
to Shannon and it's like shannon has
JumpShip onto the Kelly Train and like
when she didn't call what the heart
surgery I was like that's unforgivable
if you apologize like item removed on
Tamara is socially oh she doesn't yeah
Tamara is such a good Freddie stage on
today like I don't think they speak I
see that coming and it's and needs to
happen cuz Shannon like needs to learn
because not only yes when you friends
are supposed to be there for you during
hard times
anyone can be a friend when things are
easy and so I understand my Shannon
feels like this is part of the
friendship like I'm going through hard
times you need to be there for me but
it's also the other way around if Tamara
wasn't going through anything that's
fine you don't need to be there for her
but Tamara honestly is going through
something that's life or death like what
you're going through it's actually can
be argued is less serious course and
this is gonna be really insensitive but
like you're not the only person to have
gotten a divorce and it's like every
conversation commands Shannon's house
Shannon's feeling and what Shannon went
through and it's like please these women
everyone's going everyone has their own
[ __ ] in this world you're not the only
person who goes through pain and so to
act like you were are going through the
worst and who are having the hardest
time out of anyone it's like so selfish
and I couldn't not be friends with
someone like that agreed and I've been a
Shannon astrologist for a very long time
especially last season because she was
be she was acting out and I was like oh
this is the effects of a bad marriage
she's getting divorced you know everyone
gets a pass but her past heaven does
expired it does not apply to this season
when she literally got the deal of a
lifetime with QVC she has she's getting
child support from her husband I love
her house
I [ __ ] love her how he has amazing
care huh and all she sees is what she
doesn't have yet and that she's gained
30 pounds and like that's not the end of
the world and by the way those thirty
pounds are what gave her this new career
so I just want to be grateful for the
third about the pass has expired now
you're on QVC like you could become Lisa
Rinna she's making cards ready two grand
a month right and I want to know how
where QVC stuff is doing because
anything you can do badly on Kitty's no
because the eyeballs alone are enough to
sell it out it's great to get the show
and keep you say no but like what would
we sell no would you the show they need
some entertainment on that yet that's
true I'm sure the women get tired sit
down have a class of champagne on the
morning and I'm sure the shoppers get
tired they're like hey I keep shopping
yeah give my credit card a break okay so
we have three things to announce one in
about nine minutes my tickets to my
Detroit Michigan
are gonna go live so head over to the
link in my Instagram and also put on the
website too I added a second show in
Miami December 19th
so girls no job comm you know what to do
not invite be Rihanna and Tony know what
to do with that big fat butt
Rachael Lindsey's coming and I will
invite baby a good call
but then if Rachel's there Peter's there
oh no I'll invite them to different
shows because Rachel and Brian are
coming okay and then 30 is really
exciting and this is really exciting so
December December 18th Jackie and I are
doing a morning toast live show in New
York so basically the last day of the
toast before we gone holiday break is
December 18th in the morning that night
Jackie and I are doing a show at
Caroline's tickets are gonna go on sale
sometime today or tomorrow we will let
you know of course presale for patron
they sell for patreon it's in New York
show so New York tri-state area this is
your this is your moment and it's just
gonna be like holiday I'm gonna wear
like a very holiday look we have to go
shopping again I'm gonna wear a holiday
look I'm or such a holiday look last
night I knew you were the choker oh yeah
we're good same thing Oh cute cute okay
so it's really fun we're working on a
lot of stuff for you guys we love you
this was a great episode I'm sorry about
the poop think like we really picked it
back up no people are really enjoying
this episode okay good
thank you guys for voting here one
Detroit goes on sale in eight minutes to
two ie
Miami bienvenidos a me a me and three
tickets to our show live show very rare
v rare occasion December 18th
tickets will go on sale tomorrow we will
let you know pre sell for patreon if you
want to check it I suggest becoming a
patreon member because it feels like
it's gonna sell out yeah
Caroline's it's a morning to us holiday
extravaganza I'd say it's Trevor the
guns uh love you guys and tickets the
camp toasts are available at the Lincoln
bio password caps Kenton chant they are
selling like hotcakes
so make sure to get yours have an
amazing weekend it's been a wonderful
week with you guys
you